and I didn't need Beyonce and jay-z  [Applause]  and I didn't need little Bruce  Springsteen and all of these he was  implying that other people need to have  all that help he doesn't need that so  he's going back to 2016 this is now 2019  you surprised that he's trash-talking  you after all this time yeah anything's  possible  I mean a lot of people are very  concerned about the direction of the  country it's just frightening you know  we're living in a frightening time the  stewardship of the nation is it's been  thrown away to somebody who doesn't have  a clue as to what that means and  unfortunately have somebody who I feel  doesn't have a grasp of the deep meaning  of what it means to be an American